okay i'm trying to see if this works so
let's see hold up hold up hold up
um
[Music]
okay testing testing testing
um hold up
okay testing testing
why does it go in and out i don't
understand
okay another thing i'm going to try is
this mics yeah this sounds
but i think it's buzzing when i talk so
what i think the mic does is it
automatically
picks like like it's supposed to silence
the mics when you're not talking
so i think
it's still picking up a buzzing in the
background and it's weird because i
really don't hear it like in this room
um so i'm going to try one thing i'm
going to see if this helps i'm going to
see if i mute this third mic here
if
if this is the one that's picking up the
buzzing or if they all are because i
have a feeling it's just this one cause
i think it's more powerful
okay
all right i'm talking testing one two
three testing
testing testing
i think that sounds better right
okay that's the problem is this mic is a
different type of microphone so i think
that's why
it's picking up oh my gosh so i need
[Music]
uh
i wish i was an i had an audio engineer
that would make my life so much easier
because now the question is like what do
i do because
i still need like
these are 130 pounds each so it's like
200 each
um
[Music]
can maybe stream for a day and see if i
can make that
okay well at least i know i think what
the problem is
oh my god i'm putting a lot into this
show guys
okay wait
next question can you guys hear me from
here so if my guest doesn't talk right
in the microphone
can you hear this
the microphone
you hear this
okay now on top of that is there any
buzzing at all
any buzzing any buzzing any buzzing
no okay
research the requirement of your mics
you may just need to adjust things oh my
gosh you don't understand that i just
have like
i think with audio i am just like
stupid because i had this other mic for
like a year
and it's a really good mic but it's
meant for music not podcasting and i
could not figure it out i couldn't for
the life of me
um so i got a mic that's probably worth
a quarter what it's worth to use just
because i wouldn't have to adjust the
settings like
oh i need an audio engineer
i need an audio engineer
um
okay well this is at least good to know
for now okay
well i think i
roughly understand what i need to do
okay guys thank you
i'll talk to you later